the graph below contains triangle ABC
and the point P draw the image of
triangle ABC under dilation whose center
is P and a scale factor of 2 so
essentially we want to scale this so
that every point is going to be twice as
far away from P so for example B right
over here it's the same y-coordinate as
P but its x-coordinate is 3 times or is
3 more so we want to be twice as far so
if this maps to point B we just want to
go twice as far so we're at 3 away we
want to go 6 away so point P is
x-coordinate is at 3 now we're at 9
likewise Point C is 3 below P well we
want to go twice as far so we'll go 3
more and point a is 4 above P well we
want to go 4 more we're going to go
twice as far 1 2 3 4 and we get right
over there then they ask us what are the
lengths of side a B and it's image a B a
B right over here let's see we might
have to apply the distance formula let's
see it's the base right over here the
change in the change in X between the
two is 3 and the change in Y is 4 so
this is actually a 3 4 5 right triangle
3 squared plus 4 squared is equal to 5
squared so a B is 5 units long
essentially just using the Pythagorean
theorem to figure that out and it's
image well its images should be twice as
long and let's see whether that actually
is the case so this is a base right over
here that's of length 6 this has a
height or this change in Y I could say
if we could I'm really just trying to
figure out this length which is the
hypotenuse of this right triangle that I
don't have my drawing tool so I
apologize but this height right here is
8 so 8 squared is 64 plus 6 squared is
36 that's 100 which is 10 squared just
10 squared and so notice our scale
factor of 2 the corresponding side got
twice as long each of these points got
twice as far away from our center of
dilation